hello and welcome to DWS international
reporters magazine world stories with me
Leila hawk coming up on today's show
fruit astok creations from Bulgaria we
meet a duo who create artful bouquets
from heaps of fruit also ahead we hear
from a Palestinian filmmaker about the
difficulties he faced making a
critically acclaimed documentary and we
had too hungry to learn about a very
special Virgin Mary plus a bright idea
lights up Rwanda that's all coming up
but first scientists in Brazil are
developing nanotech applications that
could one day impact all of our lives in
a big way researchers at the federal
university of mina should eyes are
engineering carbon nanotubes that are
smaller than the eye can see to function
as devices that when injected into a
patient can be used for targeted drug
delivery sounds like science fiction to
you well although it's difficult to
picture there are loads of potential
uses but introducing a foreign object
into the body isn't without its risks
Simona Piaf hora de minas television
reports nanotechnology can play an
important role in finding cures for
severe diseases comprehensive research
in the field is indispensable and has
only just begun
wha protein upon deduction is others the
protein used in isolation has a brief
half-life and quickly disappears in the
body often it doesn't even reach the
target cells necessary for the
immunological response which is
triggering production of antibodies the
so-called delivery systems are
considerably more efficient it helps the
proteins get into the immune system
faster Wow ss protein aslam present
father's all systema knowledge all over
the world research is underway to find
intelligent medications that are able to
get at the cause of a disease without
side effects the development of carbon
nanotubes has given these efforts new
impetus so being fees are tiny tubes
consisting of carbon molecules I'm
talking about tubes with a diameter just
one nanometer their development first
started over 20 years ago these are
materials with exceptional mechanical
and thermal properties and these tubes
form a perfect nanometric needle as well
so it's a very versatile material
material keep university I dodged me to
grant a request a virus aplicaciones was
no no boo boo chica carbon nanotubes
still have to be approved for use on
human beings but that's not the only
obstacle nanotechnology has to overcome
it also has to be proven that nano
materials don't contaminate the
environment or upset the ecological
balance even so this new science of
materials invisible to the naked eye is
already affecting our daily lives the
federal university of menasha guys ufmg
is at the forefront of carbon nanotube
research in brazil the researchers here
have already been producing the material
using a variety of processes for 14
years now the institute is now working
on developing more resistant synthetic
materials and cement and it's
collaborating on a number of other
projects
in this lab nanotubes are playing a role
in research on a vaccine for dengue
fever now the adagio projection when
fazio premiere of a scene our goal is
not to develop a first dengue vaccine
but to look into a vaccine that's
affordable he isn't a possible even if
another vaccine is developed that's
effective we'll keep working on one of
our own that costs less my spotter our
vaccines are subsidized by the state
which lowers the cost and makes them
more lucrative I thought yeah there's a
hip isn't I tomorrow I'm going dengue
fever is a problem in tropical regions
the many prevention campaigns have made
little real impact in Brazil in 2012
some 65,000 people contracted dengue 23
died
another disease nanotubes could help
fight is cancer set the other [ __ ]
apples for seventy percent of patients
diagnosed with cancer will eventually
receive chemotherapy it's you know what
they are in modern medicine a basic
principle of allopathy is that
medications aren't supposed to have any
side effects here to nanotechnology
could help at the Pheo cruz institute
they are testing the use of carbon
nanotubes for a vaccine
I know they dodged this tomorrow what's
new about this work is that for the
first time we're using carbon nanotubes
as a vehicle to deliver the vaccine this
is an image of a carbon nanotube and in
the next image you see the tube surface
that the protein bonds to salida a
protein tomorrow unlike the dengue virus
and other disease-causing agents cancer
cells come from our own bodies and so
they are not recognized or attacked this
is known as immuno tolerance and that's
why conventional vaccines won't work
here the first challenge is to trigger
an immune system response the second is
to get the vaccine to protect against a
range of cancers
so he was coming to a corn Osprey
pattern here we're getting the vaccine
ready to inject into mice anything
ethical or [ __ ]' mean it has a
coloration typical of carbon black the
proteins are already bonded thousands of
molecules are contained in this to
retain healthy mice are given two doses
of vaccine 21 days apart then they are
injected with cancer cells the results
show no or only very slow tumor growth
with an overall survival rate of some
75% a chemotherapy that chemotherapy and
radiation therapy are very invasive and
have lots of serious side effects so I
believe developing less invasive
medications is very important and
valuable commands men to rajiv's wash
can we provide the same in Brazil over 7
billion euros are invested in
nanotechnological research every year
well in the meantime we may just have to
eat an apple a day to keep the doctor
away as speaking of apples in Bulgaria
to bankers have raised playing with food
to an art they run a thriving business
creating unique fruit bouquets that
stand out and according to Nova TVs
zipco konstantinov they are not only a
visual delight but a sumptuous treat as
well take a look
normally they work in a bank this is
their second source of income Martin and
vocal use every minute outside of their
daily job to arrange bouquets but not
the typical ones these are made of fruit
silver for watching Paula written this
is how we prepare the fruits which we
will then arrange in the basket
suggestion division one on us I will cut
the pineapple in the form of a daisy
whatever
zilma a dozen yellow key we take the
sliced apples and we fix them on wooden
sticks after that we dip them into
chocolate so that they're well coated
cut to the booth till we shake off the
excess so that the chocolate coating
doesn't become layer what this procedure
is repeated until every piece of the
bouquet is ready go nice what's the
strangest bouquet you've ever made I
recently we made an x-ray machine the
countdown begins now the fruit basket is
ready so necesito compared to real
flowers flowers are much more durable
and can be moistened with water if you
spray the fruits with water nothing will
happen there is one small problem though
fruit bouquets only last 24 hours that's
only a minor disadvantage not the major
advantage is that you can admire the
bouquets and then you can eat them
there's an urban eatin anova chief
Constantine now on to the amazing story
of a Palestinian farmer who a couple of
years ago got a video camera to film the
early life of his poor child as an
Israeli separation barrier was being
built at the same time he also
documented the shaping of the nonviolent
resistance in his village little did he
know that his footage would soon become
a first-person account of this
development and that it then became the
first-ever Palestinian documentary to be
nominated for an Oscar bbc's her
unnimaya caught up with the filmmaker in
2005 a mud-born art started videotaping
peaceful demonstrations in villa Inn
near Ramallah in the Palestinian
territories at the time he never would
have dreamt that one day one of his
documentaries would be nominated for an
Oscar for what many see as the most
important film prize in the world five
broken cameras tells the story of a
journalist chronicling the Palestinians
fight for their rights and so on Milly o
Shah spadina 1 billion people watch the
Academy Awards this way they can learn
about the history of Palestine the
reality of life fair and the suffering
of the Palestinians as depicted in the
lives of the inhabitants of Billy
Bernard documentary observes the
peaceful resistance in billeting and the
occupation forces who broke five of his
cameras he suffered gunshot wounds and
an almost constant danger of suffocation
but he remained undaunted and finished
his work with camera number six and
figure I can at the IML fill in many
idea corresponds to my personal story am
I seven years of experience with the
camera it gives Western audiences a
chance to consider the Palestinian cause
through the lens of personal experiences
Janelle in Brussels in sarnia definitely
Bernard chronicles event in Glavine and
the Israeli security forces treatment of
the villages and those who support them
he includes the birth and first years of
his son Gabriel and records his first
word wall at a very early age gibril
learns the concept of homeland and its
significance some of his friends even
died violent deaths in connection with
the occupation in Canada castle air i
picked up the camera to document events
in the village during that time my
fourth charger brill was born my
intention was to report on the situation
in the village on the demonstrations and
activities at the same time I wanted to
observe my son growing up and how my
closest friends and family were living
whiticus Harville makara be in one more
I la year five broken cameras was
nominated for an Academy Award in the
documentary category it's already won a
good 30 international awards and been
widely shown it bears witness to the
occupation the Palestinian people
continue to live under Allah mutual
theme five broken cameras didn't win the
Oscar but the village of Deline the one
so much more withdrawal of the security
forces and a part of its own land back
for the villagers use rd hub hartal na
Mele Philistine but I'm a lot and now
too hungry were in a small town a ritual
takes place on every second Friday when
the statue of the Virgin Mary is dressed
up in a different outfit and not just
any dress will do elaborate gals and
unique cloaks from all over the world
adorn this devotional statuette a dress
collection is so extensive it got its
own small Museum MTV A's birth olivia
has more
or me gets along god they've been
dressing our devotional statues in 1747
when the church was consecrated
searching equally encounters quad
alliance a genie donated the first cloak
for the statute it's a warmer as I
theaters name at the Virgin Mary
statuette is dressed every second Friday
morning the oldest cloak we have dates
back to 1852 while the newest one was
made in September 2012 these little
cloaks express the gratitude of
individuals families and the local
churches because with the help of Virgin
Mary they grow close to Jesus here in
this special place and God heard their
prayers hi Ben chulada Rach Rach Oscar
shear I've o Krishna he'll run it
assures here now there are seven
different dress patterns for clothes
from different parts of the country azu
Machoke microbiota shot a lot in the
paint one day a young mother phoned us
she asked me to send one of these
patterns to budapest yes of ash mean
that budapest raquel attack ruthanne am
she said she needed it to fulfill the
pledge SAMCRO OHV oh toledo sonya
telephone out two years earlier she had
prayed here in this holy place for a
babyish an automatic assault kit evil
eyes of God granted her wish so she
wanted to make a cloak for the statuette
based on the dress pattern so wash means
all of young Sarah nuh as he dedicates a
warlock it gave me great pleasure to
send the pageant to her in all of them
Obama especially when I heard the voice
of her baby over the phone God had heard
her prayers are you Retta issues are for
what Asher
the monatomic news'matt Himalayas are
jewels who was the church deacon founded
the Museum of the cloaks at Virgin Mary
them for you my task is to preserve
these tributes that symbolized the
gratitude of people whose prayers came
true the statuette already bought this
car launches style cloak what about the
Bulls out today it's beautiful same
position um it's been a long time since
she last wore this cloak noni retro girl
a lot of the garments were sent from
abroad
hiya doc lasagna Madonna of the
Hungarians Mary Von Dutch say your
prayers for the Hungarians who are
living abroad November the first
nineteen seventy julep Bob a venezuela
Caracas Hitler tato here we see a photo
of the Tour de family thank you they
donated several dresses octoberish Randy
this way the museum became a symbol of
respect for the Virgin Mary and the
unity of the Hungarian people morocco
sat or toes Hashanah wishes a cover
maggoty can be I'd like to show you the
oldest cloak in our collection it dates
back to 1852 war on gray it was donated
by contest silly barangay and it's made
of blue velvet which is the most robust
cloth this cloak is the most precious
piece in our Museum get so long as the
statue came from culture people have
been sending colocho embroidery and
similar patterns for several centuries
shows aqua these little cloak stand for
the visitors affection mukesh de la in
aussie afterthought don't want or i find
it very important for this dress
collection to keep growing at least
because it preserves folk patterns from
all regions of hungary multivan wait ela
to lag in or black box moreover for me
as a priest these intricately detailed
folk patterns express the deepest
affection of people's hearts that will
all upset at it music and every stitch
expresses the dressmaker's fondest
devotion when on okc tunic ah lagu da da
da da
now turning to Africa what's easier than
switching on the lights most of us don't
give it much thought but in sub-saharan
Africa millions live without electricity
when night falls in rural areas of
Rwanda businesses can't operate and
students can't do their homework now a
team of engineers and entrepreneurs are
plugging into entire communities and
hooking them up with LED lights that use
solar or manpower bringing light where
once there was darkness called gear
store for reports when the sun goes down
in Equatorial Africa it gets dark within
minutes here in rural Rwanda there is no
electricity a kerosene lamp is the only
way to defy the darkness 12 year old
Rebecca does her homework in the pale
lamplight a tragic accident when she was
tiny scarred her for life her mother vez
teen will never forget that moment of
inattention she was still a baby and was
sleeping I went outside briefly and when
I came back the kerosene lamp had fallen
onto the floor the curtains had already
caught fire I tried to stamp out the
flame so the fire wouldn't spread and a
piece of flaming curtain fell onto
Rebecca's face and burned her Big O
Father that [ __ ] sick the Mughal
mamasa we didn't go to the house in
addition to causing accidents like this
kerosene accounts for 150 million tons
of carbon emissions annually it's a
fossil fuel that damages the climate so
in the capital kigali a team of
inventive engineers and entrepreneurs
are working on an alternative after all
the mobile phone industry has already
shown that technological innovation can
thrive in remote regions but Samir [ __ ]
the driving force behind the project
knows there's a major obstacle yes but
the reality is
seventy-four percent of sub-saharan
Africa had access to electricity in 2011
it was ten percent you know six percent
added to the grid over the past forty
years it's not really a fantastic record
and so we we recognize that and are
trying to develop a solution here that's
going to address the problem immediately
bright LEDs are her step since using
them reduces carbon emissions they
generate carbon credits money that
Sameer reinvests summer and his
colleagues are testing their nuru lights
in a pilot project they hire local
entrepreneurs who know their customers
very well
demand was enormous but there was the
issue of how to recharge the batteries
at first they were experimenting with
solar technology but they soon
recognized that that was too
short-sighted although there is a common
perception that the Sun is always
shining in Africa there are many months
during the year during rainy seasons for
example where the Sun isn't shining as
you would expect and solar isn't the
most reliable technology so you know we
we looked at solar initially when we
were doing product development and you
know we decided that you know there was
an another untapped energy source in
rural Africa which has been used for
centuries and that's human power
entrepreneurs become energy providers
their muscle power feeds a simple
generator 20 minutes of pedaling can
recharge five batteries that costs ten
cents alight a fraction of the price of
kerosene with normal use the batteries
last a whole week what could be more
efficient
Martin Hawaii a zoo earns money both by
recharging batteries and by selling the
lights and he has plenty of customers
you never said which arose in my
business keeps growing and growing last
year i sold a hundred and seventy-five
nearer lights and i think this year i
can almost double that to three hundred
and welcome the LED lights aren't just
brightening up everyday life in rural
rwanda they're also helping to tap
economic potential daniel is one of many
fishermen in the wetlands along the
econo Auto River he's using soap as bait
to catch nocturnal catfish the bait is
prepared during the last minutes of
daylight and then set out as soon as
it's dark the bait has to be taken in
again orientation is difficult in the
marshes so many of the fishermen here
have now bought Martin's nuru lights it
makes their work much easier reeling in
the nets and laying out the bait again
used to be much harder with kerosene and
flashlights
in a few hours a dozen catfisher caught
profit margins are tight so Daniel and
his fellow fishermen have to use the
night as efficiently as possible it's
only since they've had the LEDs that the
catch has become really profitable now
the fishermen can finally put a little
money aside what Elmo's Aquila and these
LEDs have really changed my life I used
to use an electric torch and had to
spend lots of money on batteries almost
nothing was left for me indeed I you
have to understand I was penniless I
come from the street but now that I can
cover my costs I've been able to buy a
house for a quarter of a million francs
and I can even get married making use of
equatorial nights far from the power
grid has become easier and safer thanks
to LED technology rebecca has been
scarred by kerosene but she's looking
optimistically to the future at least
the darkness will no longer keep her
from studying well that's our show for
today thanks so much for joining us
we're out of time but you can always
watch us online at DW de / world stories
we're also on Facebook drop us a line
we'd love to hear from you now here are
this week's picks of the world see you
next time
you
you